the Joe Rogan experience there's been
many instances of sightings off the
coast of California of things that
plunge into the water or escape from the
water and take off into space
so yeah the with the field propulsion
system as commander favors describing as
Lazar described it doesn't matter the
medium of space air or water there's no
resistance no splash and this goes back
to you know when Christopher Columbus
reported a UFO sighting he did oh yeah
did this idea that so this has been
around anyway this idea boom that you
can go through these different mediums
pause for sodium Christopher Columbus or
the UFO silence yeah it's it's a written
account so it's like find that no video
it's [ __ ] let's see but that's
what's so cool so commander framers
encounter it's not the most documented
it's not the most dramatic however it
has had the most impact out of any
sighting because of his credibility and
the mere fact that the the New York
Times picked it up with video footage
radar evidence and somebody who is as
credible as commander forever it has
changed the dynamic of the way people
the government responds new Navy
protocols because of commander flavor
coming forward there are there are
closed-door congressional and Senate
briefings he's been part of them he's
admitted that before there's a new study
about UFOs because of this encounter
it's so much evidence has so much power
to it compared to other ones so
Christopher Columbus great cool story
somebody wrote it down who knew who
knows if he even wrote it down we have
highly documented cases this one has
changed our culture and that's what's so
cool people are talking about it
differently so here's a good story this
is it true
so I'll sitting at home and usually when
people try and find me they get my wife
cell phone because it's the first one on
the cell phone ville and it's on my name
so I get I see this call from California
and I'm like ignore me I don't answer
him
and it's her phone like who's calling my
wife because that is me
so I answer it and this lady says hey is
commander for over there and I go who's
calling and she goes well I'd like to
talk to him at her forever I go who's
calling and she says
hi I'm a 79 year old woman and I would
just like to tell him my story I go
you're talking to him and she goes I've
never in my life told anyone this
she goes my I grew up my dad was in the
Navy she goes I was he was stationed in
Rhode Island at first when she was a
child she said we were walking her and
her mom while walking on the beach and
they saw these weird lights so that kind
of got her into that Oh UFOs she goes
few years later they had moved to San
Francisco so I imagined Treasure Island
because at her age that would have been
you know part in the 50s her dad was
[ __ ] her dad is working as a Navy
liaison to the agency and he came home
one day and he had a telegram in his
hand and she goes for some reason he let
me read it she's telling me this story
and I said well what did say she says it
was it basically said hey unidentified
objects going in and out of the water
and it had a latitude and longitude in
it and he looked at her she goes and I'm
a child I always remember that she says
he looked at me and said we get these
all the time and it's always in the same
area and I go of course I go well you
got the telegram she goes of course not
he had to take it back to work I said
you don't have to remember that
latitude/longitude she said no she goes
but you seem to be so credible and
believable she goes I wanted to tell
someone the story that I've never told
anyone in my life so that's what you're
starting to see is people that you know
very credible they're not you know
they're not they're not crazy they're
not making stuff up but they're coming
out and going hey I've had these
experience and I've got a lot of that
from for over the last two years where
people just find my email and send me
stuff saying hey this happened to me or
I saw this and and there's some things
are explainable because I got asked to
tell this so because we're kind of I
have a sixth sense of humor at time so
like I said I had all these koala
used to fly they don't do it right now
because it's a little bit dangerous but
we used to fly night-vision goggles low
altitude in Hornets all right so when
you put on night-vision goggles they
amplify light like a lot so you can see
a campfire like 50 miles away so we used
to do it the good spots were down in
Lake Isle central California there's a
range that there's some bombing ranges
but people go camping in the
Superstition Mountains which is a kind
of north and west of Imperial by
I forget what it is the springs it's
real prison a desert it'll come to me in
a minute so we even go out at night
flying around on goggles and you'd see a
campfire and you go up UFO time and then
you get the airplane going about six
hundred knots and then you pull the
power back to idle so you can't hear it
and you get zinging towards the fire
well you turn the lights are out now
because we're in restricted area so we
can do that and there's lights on it
that you can only see if you're on
night-vision goggles so the other
airplanes can see us but no one else can
see us then you go zinging at it and
then right when you get to the campfire
you pull the airplane into the vertical
yes stroke the afterburners you let them
light off you count to three you pull
them off and then you just go away
instant UFO reporting I'm sitting out in
the desert it's all quiet and all of a
sudden there's a lure there's lights in
the sky and they go away and it's gone
like you would do that just to [ __ ] with
campers yes yes yes I did I'm not the
only one that did it but like I said we
have a sick sense of humor yes sure
so some things are explainable because I
guarantee there were phone calls made on
some of the stuff that we did and I
guarantee you're not the only one who's
ever done that I know I'm not yeah I'm
not that creative but it's just you know
you think about it ego because people go
I saw this or I saw that because I've
got stuff like that and I go yeah I used
to create stuff like that just not toes
[Applause]